toutes choses en conclusion dans ce
rapport caviardé de 448 pages diffère du
résumé de quatre pages publié par le
procureur général aux morts le 24 mars
dernier malgré la centaine de contacts
de l'équipe chambre avec des russes et
les nombreux mensonges
le procureur spécial robert morin ne
peut conclure au complot n'est cependant
pas convaincu que dans nos jobs n'a pas
essayé d'entraver la justice les
différentes tentatives du président de
mettre un frein à l enquête du procureur
spécial empêche dernier de l'exonérer le
rapport révèle la panique du président
lors de la nomination de mauvais en mai
c'est terrible c'est la fin de ma
présidence je suis foutu at il déclaré
le procureur mme maulin analyser une
dizaine de scénarios ou d'un autre chien
pas poser des gestes pour nuire à son
enquête
lorsqu'il a par exemple congédié le
directeur du fbi à et jim thome tenté de
renvoyer le procureur spécial rapporte
me le demander à son ex procureur
général jeff sessions de reprendre la
direction de l'anc aide ou encore essayé
de l'imiter l'anc est mauvais rob huff
mans lui conclu que ces tentatives d'
entrave ont souvent échoué parce que les
membres de l'équipe du président à la
maison blanche ont refusé d'obéir à ses
hommes
dans notre homme crie victoire et se
considère exonéré de tout blâme les
démocrates demandent au procureur
spécial et au procureur général de
comparaître devant le sénat le plus
rapidement possible le rapport moral et
maintenant public et les démocrates vont
utiliser chaque parcelle pour continuer
de nuire au président chante avec la
preuve accumulée lors de son
investigation
le procureur spécial roberte maurer a
référé 14 enquêtes différentes unités
judiciaire on ignore sur qui et sur quoi
portent ces enquêtes
mais il ya fort à parier que les
problèmes juridiques de dans notre
chambre et de son entourage sont loin
d'être terminées ici christian latreille
radio-canada washington